-2019, you were here.
We were talking about
who should the nominee be.
You were making the argument
that the nominee should be
somebody who would
excite the base.
I got the sense --
I think we both agreed --
that maybe that wasn't
Joe Biden.
Do you think, looking back
you underestimated
how he would perform
as a candidate?
I know --
Mea culpa on my own part.
I think I underestimated him
certainly
in so far as the kind
of campaign he ran.
-Right. Except, you know,
the first three primaries
and caucuses, Bernie won
the popular vote in all three.
Biden was fourth, fifth, sixth
So it didn't look like
it was going to happen.
And even the party, um --
whatever you call the part
hacks that run the party -
they panicked
and changed the rules
to get Bloomberg on that stage
and in the campaign.
Remember that?
They had collectively decided,
"Oh, shoot,
Biden's not going to make it
We got to get Bloomberg
in here
and we got to change the rules
so he can debate."
So I think that, yes --
Honestly, I think,
now looking back,
I think Biden
did the right thing.
He was criticized
constantly by Trump
for being in the basement,
but that's exactly
where I think I would have been,
with "SportsCenter" on,
because Trump
was defeating himself.
The more Biden
just let Trump talk,
the more that Biden just -
the more that Trump
just kept doing one
wackadoodle thing after another,
that -- that was going to
guarantee his defeat.
And they asked people
now in these last couple weeks
who voted for Biden,
"What's the number-one reaso
why you voted for Biden?"
58% said, "Because
I wanted to defeat Trump.
I wanted to remove Trump."
So that's still the number-one
reason that they wanted.
But I honestly believe --
Maybe I'm wrong,
but I want to hang
onto some belief that Bide
is going to seize this moment.
You know,
happy birthday by the way.
He's 78 years old here.
And he knows that he's in that
final quarter of his life.
And so I think
when people get to that age,
they want to go out believin
they've done something profound,
that they've really made
a difference.
You don't want to go out
because you passed
a good tax bill or trade bil
or whatever.
You want to go out
because you saved
the people of the United States,
because women finally
were equal under the law,
that the racism and the violence
against Black people
was going to somehow
come to an end,
that we were going to stop
this mass incarceration
and all these things
that he has a chance
to be remembered
in the way we remember,
say, John F. Kennedy,
who was president
for two and a half, two an
three quarters years. That's it.
And yet look
how he's remembered.
So Biden has that chance.
And the people
want him to succeed.
I really believe that.
And I do.
And there's so much to get done.
All of us have to be
actively involved in this.
We have to get the Senate.
We all have to do
whatever we can
to help out in Georgia
between now and January 5th.
Everybody in Georgia, you've
got to get registered to vot
by December 7th.
If you're 17 and you're up
watching Seth right now
because there's
no school to go tomorrow,
you can vote in this
if you turn 18 by January 5th.
You could register right now
at 17 years old.
So these are the things we nee
to be active and involved in
and we've got more work to do,
but we get to play offense
We get the -- The quarterback,
in his heart, is with us.
And that's not a bad thing
Not a bad thing at all.
-I don't want to leave
without you having a chanc
to be pessimistic
about something.
I do -- I have heard
you're a little worried
about the turkey pardon.
-Oh, yeah, that's right.
That's coming up on Tuesday.
The pardon every year.
You know, the President
pardons the turkey.
And I'm so worried about -
First of all, don't let
your children watch this
because things are so craz
with Trump right now.
This is going to be the one year
where the President
doesn't pardon the turkey.
The president is going to
friggin' kill the turkey.
He's going to wrap his hands
around that turkey's neck
or he's going to call Eric i
with one of his
safari hunting guns.
Something bad is going to happen
with Tommy Turkey.
And this is --
All I want to think about
when I think about Thanksgivin
is that the Meyers family --
Is it going to happen this year?
-We're being hopeful.
We're trying to quarantine
so that we can do it safel
next week.
-Okay. I understand why
because people watching this
need to not have --
Unless they're in the same
family in the same house,
I think
we've got to forego this.
But, you know, it always bring
a little cheer to the fans here.
-We're gonna do what we can.
You'll see them no matter what
Whether they're here in person
or via Zoom, they'll be here
-They will be there.
And Tommy Turkey --
Please somebody
protect that bird, please.
That's all I'm asking.
-"Rumble with Michael Moore"
is available wherever
you get your podcasts.